[Music]
alright Here I am as New York City
burned
here's what governor Antiqua most said
Tuesday on Twitter there are those who
want to intentionally blur the lines
between peaceful legitimate protesters
and looters the president is among them
they want you to watch the videos of the
looting not the video of mr. Floyd being
murdered don't fall for it so a governor
whose citizens and taxpayers are under
attack
claims the biggest problem is witnessing
the attack the mayhem the looting
attacks on cops because that blurs the
lines between peaceful protests and
looters I suppose he would prefer you
watch this over and over again this was
the actual swab that was being used to
fit up that double-barrel shotgun that
you have mounted on the front of your
pretty face I will never get tired of
that so who is blurring the lines
between protesters and looters it's not
me
it's people like him because every time
you mentioned the rioters they accuse
you of smearing protesters we do
understand the difference does he do you
remember when you condemned to actions
of jihadists and suddenly they accused
you of Islamophobia that when you
criticize the headings that was the same
as calling all Muslims extremists that
idiotic response revealed who does the
blurring and it's that blurring that
hurts the protest movement but by
exposing the violent mob you protect the
future of legitimate protest not doing
it forever links it to destruction in
death while saying or implying that
black grievance only matters if it's
expressed violently that's nuts
if that's what you're saying Andy you're
you're the one sowing discord you're the
one who left us hanging sacrificing
citizens to the mob just so we don't
blur any of your precious lines Laura to
go back to the iDEN in the a block I
wasn't aware of the victim's brother
coming out and basically saying exactly
the point and the thing is I think both
sides of this debate agree that
conflating protests and rioting is wrong
we just want
both sides to identify them as different
and then we'd be happy or just go and
pick up the bad guys so we can have a
peaceful protest like just go pick him
up I mean as I'm walking home from the
studio I see them just lollygagging in
my neighborhood and I just don't
understand why didn't they pick them up
I mean auntie for just lurking in the
street but I do have a message because
you know today is a day that we
reflected on George Florida and the
memory that he had and there's been a
lot of talk about his past and you know
George Florida was he had a pass but
guess what in America and as a believer
this is a place for Redemption and he
turned his life around and he worked
hard and he decided that he was going to
do community groups with people in Bible
studies that's what we want to remember
and so I said that all to say this to
the protesters and the looters the
protesters are doing it the right way
but the looters you got to ultimately
pick a side Joyce Floyd picked the side
and he decided to turn his life around
you can do the same like there's no
reason to destroy your entire community
there's no reason to do that doesn't
bring him honor the family has said it
does not bring him honor you look look
at his past videos he doesn't like that
so at this point you're doing it for
yourself yeah you don't want one thing
that I do I noticed that I find funny is
that the black members of the protest
movement are sickened by the rioters and
the agitators
but it's the white liberals in the
activist groups who are careful to
virtue signal and not actually say
anything about the rioting and looting
it's it's the blacks in the protest
movie movement who understand the danger
of the rioting more than anybody else
like mr. Florence Floyd's brother well
you know look I don't think it's a you
know I think you often talk about the
prison of two ideas so let's get out of
the two ideas yeah because to me it's
not a zero-sum game right to me you can
condemn the looting
criminal activity but you can also
condemn what happen in terms of that
awful torturous murder of George Floyd
so looting and rioting you say it's just
black people let me just say the facts I
say this as someone who studied the
civil rights movement in the 1960s which
provided such tremendous social change
for our country that it was a
non-violent social protest movement a
lot of times the violence came from the
government or from white supremacists it
didn't come from the protesters and they
achieved real solid change and so I
would say to all of the country at this
moment that building coalitions for
change persuading people of the goodness
of your cause is about peaceful protest
that's why I'm so pleased to see that we
have had so much more peaceful protests
in the last few days
one last thing Greg I just wanted to
disagree with you on what you had said
about this society I wanted to just
quote something I read today from condi
rice a strong Republican someone we all
know who said this society is not
colorblind and probably never will be
and until we're honest that race is an
anchor around our country's neck that
shadow will never be lifted well thank
you for that one and you're dead wrong
about what I said I didn't say it was
just black people you took you took what
I said incorrectly and that was really
bad I said it's black people who were
upset at the rioting I didn't say it was
just black people rioting and I wish you
wouldn't have said that yeah you said
it's not what I like it's not just but I
did not all right why I heard it so Dana
no I said it's not just black people who
are upset at the rioting Greg now I
didn't hear it that way well if you said
it that way I apologize but this is a
show in which people can get things
right most of the time and sometimes I
get things wrong
which is rare one it is rare that I get
things very rare very rare very rare
Dana what Dana
so one brings up the condi rice quote
which I find interesting because no one
is denying that racist exists right I am
denying that it's a racist society that
can't exist simultaneously yeah and I
think one of the things that condi rice
also has said in the past that I always
stuck with me is that America was born
with a birth defect and we've been
dealing with that birth defect for a
long time and obviously we there was a
nation that fought our nation fought a
war over it and I think what you're
saying is also you there is opportunity
here for all of us to believe in the
American ideal because America is not a
country where we are just shared sharing
bloodlines we we came together because
of ideas and that's what holds us
together right that's the fabric that's
the glue so you can't let anybody try to
take that away from us as a nation so
when foreign nations like Bill Barre
said today that foreign nations have
been trying to use this to create more
tension within our country
ignore them do not worry about what
other nations are thinking and when it
comes to and Tifa for example Henry
Rogers over at the Daily Caller called
every single Democratic senators office
today and asked for some sort of
condemnation got none there's none so
maybe they aren't blurring lines they
maybe have maybe have drawn a very clear
line yeah Katie what are your thoughts
yeah
well Greg I want to get back to your
point about the blurring the lines
between the protesters and the rioters
and a lot of it has to do with these
Democrats were in charge not wanting to
take responsibility for what has gone on
whether it's Bill DeBlasio Governor
Cuomo the mayor of DC and also when you
blur those two lines you actually do a
disservice to the very people you say
and claim that you are standing up for
and protecting so for example the black
woman in the Bronx who lost her store to
looters who said I'm black my black life
matters and now my store which I
partially owned and work
or has been destroyed and the jobs of
the people who work here have been
destroyed what about the the black
officers who have been killed as a
result of these riots and so there needs
to be a distinction between the two for
the sake of accountability and
preventing the very communities that are
impacted the most by this from being
hurt further by a group that has
completely hijacked the narrative and
the cause on this and if you want people
to take this seriously
you want people to move forward with
unity you have to make the distinction
so people know that the two groups are
not mixed or they're going to see them
as one and according to a lot of people
on the ground that's not what's
happening here
all right before we come back I'm going
to look at the tape of me and Juan and
if he's wrong I'm tp'ing his house and I
am I'm very good at tp'ing houses Juan
trust may have a lot of toilet paper you
can always TP right do not watch TV a
shortage
yeah the shortage I know I know but I'm
good saving an update for his house yes